secretary of state for the environment
food and rural affairs is with us george
eustis hello to you good morning
uh yesterday it wasn't a big problem
today how big a problem is it
well we've been working closely with the
food industry uh both the manufacturers
and the retailers over the last week or
so
monitoring the situation closely looking
at
indices such as late deliveries to
individual stores
and absence levels and the industry had
some concerns at the end of last week
but we've been keeping it under close
review
what's clear is that early this week at
those absence levels
got to about 15 in some cases 20 percent
and that's why we decided to act swiftly
to make sure
that the food supply chain can continue
to function normally how many people are
going to be exempt from
having to isolate if they're picked well
under the scheme that we've put forward
now for the food sector we've identified
close to 500 key sites that
includes around 170 supermarket depots
and then another couple of hundred key
manufacturers like our bread
manufacturers
dairy companies and so on and uh all of
the people working in those key
strategic sites
distribution depots and those
manufacturing facilities
will be able to use this scheme and it's
probably well over 10 000 people
yeah i see the thing is when the
minister was sitting there yesterday
who's giving me the impression that i
was overreacting by saying that there
was a problem
well i think he was right in the sense
that um
there wasn't a problem in that we had
some stress starting to come on the
system
but we were working closely with
industry and it was really during the
course
of yesterday uh having had further
discussions with them
seeing that abstinence rates uh had
increased to a level
uh that was starting to concern us and
that it was likely now to continue to
increase a bit further it was that that
decided
uh decided the situation and we acted
swiftly you know we're never going to
take risks with our food supply
and that's why we've acted in the way we
have a lot of red tape still though
isn't there i mean people have to apply
to be exempt
it's not as straightforward as just
saying okay you can come in have you
been pinned
well there's two separate uh schemes so
um we have one for the future
of course we yeah and and i know these
encounters seem complicated so
for sectors like um the nuclear power
industry
the rail network uh the water industry
where you have um a small number of
um highly skilled professionals that you
need to ensure can
uh come to work uh we're having an
exemption for them
as well where they um and it's quite a
narrow exemption
for the food sector it's very different
uh this is a
uh you know quite a quite a big example
they don't need to apply
uh they don't need to apply but we are
working with all of those
um uh food companies we've identified
the 500 sites they will
the sites will be designated and then
they'll be able to operate this at a
site level
yeah you see the thing is the
hospitality sector is not included is
it's been one of the hardest hits
throughout the pandemic
could they potentially going forward be
added to the list
well look obviously um for everyone in
the middle of august we intend to move
to a
a different system for now um
i think not no so we are obviously
keeping everything under review
the reason we've made a special
exception for food is for
very obvious reasons we need to make
sure that we maintain our food supply we
will never take risks with our
food supply when it comes to other
sectors yes of course the fact that they
are also carrying
high absence levels is causing some
stress for them and it's making it
more difficult but you also have to bear
in mind why we're doing this and we are
trying to still just
dampen uh that the pace and the velocity
at which
uh this infection is spreading because
we have to keep a very close eye
on those hospitalizations we know that
if people are double jabbed
then between 92 and 96
reduction in hospitalizations is what we
can expect
but there will still be some
hospitalizations and sadly still
some deaths and we just need to make
sure that we don't have this
growing too quickly and that's the aim
of this so it could get worse before it
gets better is what you're saying
absolutely yeah it is likely to because
hospitalizations
uh do follow the um you know
the infection rate by two to three weeks
so that's why we're we're doing this i
know it's frustrating for everybody but
we do want to try to just um dampen the
curve of this infection until that uh
until it turns and things start to
go in the other direction and then of
course we can move to a different system
for everyone okay
um given that it could get worse before
it gets better is the military on
standby
um we don't have any um need or plans at
the moment to use the military but of
course they're always
on standby we always have that option to
call on the uh the contingency that the
the mod
always have in place for situations but
we don't need that at the moment well
given things changed so quickly i mean
as i said minister sitting there
yesterday a very different story to what
we're getting from you today
it would be foolish foolhardy not to
have them on standby wouldn't it they're
always on standby we have a
a standing uh part of the uh the army
that is always there should it need to
be
called on uh we never know for instance
when we're going to have a major flood
incident that might affect us
and in those situations we regularly
have troops that are on standby that can
be
uh called on at the drop of a hat that's
a standard procedure in government
and 16th of august um was the date when
people who were double jab don't have to
self-isolated they've been pinged
at the previous health secretary uh
jeremy hunt of course would be prime
minister
uh is saying that that should be brought
forward
well look i know um people are saying
these things i'd understand
the case and obviously we've adopted a a
different uh approach
already in the context of the food
sector which we've announced and we've
done that expeditiously quickly because
it's needed to be done
uh in that way we're keeping everything
obviously under review
all of the time but the reason uh we're
maintaining uh the current
system of uh test and track and isolate
is that we know that if someone's been
in contact uh with somebody who's
tested positive who's infectious uh they
are five times more likely
to uh pick up the virus themselves that
then
contributes significantly to the spread
of the virus so we're doing this
to try to dampen the spread so that we
can keep that
peak in hospitalizations at the lowest
possible level
so it could come forward um well at the
moment
it's not coming forward um so we are
could it be extended further
well we've got a clear plan and until we
are you work on data not dates don't you
uh we we do work on date and updates and
um
the key test for us is really uh the
point at which
um things start to turn and we we are
confident that we are past
the peak in infections and then we can
anticipate the peak in hospitalizations
to come
nice afterwards i understand but you
know you've been a hostage to fortune
when it's come to dates previously and
you've had to move them uh here and
there
is it a fool's errand to set dates
well i think people want to have a clear
idea of where they stand and the reason
we have set that date and of course it
you know can always things can always
change in either direction but
the reason we set these dates is to give
people some kind of indication about
what they can expect and that's why the
prime minister
set out his route map to get out of the
lockdown
he was clear that he wanted each step to
be irreversible but we would take each
step
with a degree of caution and until we
can see really this rise in the
infection
level off and start to to dip downwards
um it would be premature to
to prevent and to depart from the
approach that we've got
where are we with vaccine passports
well we've made clear uh this week that
when it comes to the
you know younger people who want to
attend nightclubs we're going to make it
a
requirement from the end of september
that they would need a
effectively to be double jabbed in order
to go into those venues
those venues are much you know higher
risk obviously they're very crowded
we think actually there is a case
football terraces though
yes well in some so what happened with
the football with england's scotland
game that
you know there were super spreaders who
came who were here and then
caught it and went back up to school
well look we're looking there's a range
of different approaches you can have you
can have
uh testing arrangements so that people
have to test before they go to those
venues so that you don't have people
with the infection and the virus going
into those um
you know that double jabbing is always
obviously an option we don't want to
use it more than we need to um the prime
minister has been very clear for
instance that we we definitely want to
avoid
using it in pubs and so on uh but as
well
terraces well as we chart our way out of
this you know we can't rule anything out
but i know that uh
uh the government set out earlier this
week um some of the
type of situations where it could be
used so yeah but there's no clarity on
that and of course we're around the
corner from the football season what's
the thought
well then we're talking about um major
events
big conferences those are the but mainly
indoor ones those are the types
of situations uh theaters it is a
possibility and i know you know theaters
themselves are actually
looking for an option that's going to
enable them to start to open
with a degree of confidence so um they
want that
ability to be able to open with
confidence and it's something that we
are considering about tory party
conference
well as i say it could be that business
conferences
including possibly party conferences
where you have large numbers of people
indoors uh there could be a case for it
there um you know we haven't
uh ruled that out but we are as i say
working through this we haven't made
finals some of your backbenchers said
don't you dare if you do that we are not
coming to party conference what would
you say to them
well look party conference is still some
way away and uh
at the moment we're very much focused on
trying to get this current infection
to to level off watching it very closely
making sure we keep
hospitalizations down um you know we may
be able to
refine the approach have different
decisions as we uh go through
later in the autumn we'll be able to
review things then in light of
how the situation's developing but you'd
rather go for the safety of the many
than the
um stubbornness of the few
look we want to have the option to be
able to do the right thing
based on the evidence we have when we're
there and what the prevalence of the
virus is
it's very difficult to predict exactly
where it'll be we've got a high degree
of confidence that we've
severed the link between infection and
hospitalization
um but it's been reduced by about 95
percent
there's still a residual risk there
that's why we still need to
show a little bit of caution but um you
know we are confident that we're going
to be able to keep that hospitalization
down and return to life closer to normal
but we may still need to have
certain tools at our disposal and we
shouldn't take them off the table does
that include wearing a mask because you
told me you didn't want to
well i don't want to wear a mask no but
i am still i can tell you uh wearing a
mask on trains
and in crowded areas and i think it's
the courteous thing to do if you go to a
shop and they are asking you to
wear a mask and have that on the door
you know of course you should do the
right thing and continue to wear it
i'd love to get to the the time when we
no longer have to wear masks i find them
very uncomfortable
but while they still perform a function
in dampening the spread of the virus and
while
people are asking me to do it on trains
and in shops i'll continue to another
couple of things while
we've got you uh the police federation
has no confidence in the home secretary
do you
of course i do yes i work very closely
with pretty and uh
i've got great confidence and if you
look at what she's done on policing
we've uh
seen the recruitment of an extra uh
eight thousand police officers we've
seen an increase in we're playing with
those figures i'm not going to go into
the figures today because as you know
you cut 21 000 but yeah
but she's uh under her watch we've been
increasing police numbers
and it's also um the case that she's
taken action to make sure the police
have got
uh the powers that they need to do their
job and to remove some of the
frustrations so
i think she's doing a fine job as far as
home secretary okay but if the nfu for
example
said they want you to go would you go um
well i probably wouldn't if i thought i
was doing the job right my view on these
things is um
let's ignore the unions well look you uh
in this role in politics um whatever job
you're in you will get a degree of
criticism there will be things
you have to do that may well be the
right thing to do but aren't always
popular with everyone
um that's par for the course it goes
with the territory you never thought for
a second though when you agreed to go
into politics to
to serve for the greater good that you'd
have to deal with what you've had to
deal with over the last 18 months
well it's been an extraordinary 18
months but for the whole country so
yes of course huge pressure on our
political system and on
government a huge responsibility to try
to get this right
um but also um let's bear in mind it's
been
a much bigger trauma for the nhs who've
had to cope with this
all those key workers all those
businesses that have struggled as well
that is where our main concern is
because they've been the most effective
we're out of time just want to ask you
about the rugby world cup australia and
new zealand have said they are not
coming they've been referred to as uh
cowards by uh rugby
league people here i'm not sure if
you're a rugby league fan you're
probably more of the union fan i'm
guessing
but what are your thoughts about them
not coming well you know i think it is a
choice for them so
i i wouldn't use um that type of
language but at the same time
you know we do want to try to move back
to um life
well um you know i hope that they might
but i'm not going to
second-guess a decision that they make
you know every country in the world is
having to make
difficult decisions based on their own
circumstances we've had to take
decisions that
not every other country in the world
would have liked but we're all wrestling
with this difficult situation it doesn't
bode well for the cricket and
and uh the test and thing the um no and
obviously
you know with the european cup and
everything we've tried to facilitate
those sporting events to try and ensure
that things can try to get back to
normal
so i you know i think it's disappointing
but it is ultimately a decision for them
okay you're gonna get me in trouble if
you don't go so i better let you go
thank you very much
for joining us as always thank you
you